um i actually went to two super bowls
that john madden and pat summerall the
greatest announcing team oh yes i ever
heard they called both games i went when
we lost to the packers and brett favre
and um when we won against the rams in
and um
i got like
i remember you know going back because i
went to the game and i would tape it and
watch it afterwards i remember going
back and watching the loss and just
thinking is john madden ever going to be
able to say that you know the patriots
won one and and when i was at that game
and the patriots kicked it and won it
the the thing that was on i was so
freaked out about this is back in the
days of vcrs did my vcr tape
because i want to hear what he's saying
about my finally john madden with all of
his knowledge is going to say something
great about
you know our team